less than 50 kilometers from the vast
wealth of Silicon Valley Michele Becerra
her daughter and granddaughter live in a
dilapidated trailer without running
water or indoor plumbing thank God we
have somewhere to stay
you know because that's the hardest part
we've been going everywhere to the
shelter's and every place trying to find
somewhere to live
three-year-old Phoenix is one of
millions of American children living in
poverty the family asked us not to show
the toddler's face to protect her
privacy we basically told her we're
going camping for this summer so that's
she's think she thinks we're going you
know Network here camping nearby a
community service organization called
loaves & Fishes serves free meals I'm
seen at the Salvation Army shelter it's
really hard especially I have three kids
one more ADHD it's hard they get
depressed they get stressed out Raymond
Kanaka runs the Watsonville social
services organization community bridges
it's really you know two things it's the
rising cost of housing and it's the
stagnant wages the reality is that the
knees are systemic their systemic based
on a capitalism that has gone awry the
amount of affordable housing for very
low-income families fell by more than
60% since 2010 the Trump administration
has proposed slashing eight billion
dollars for subsidized housing and to
triple rents paid by seven hundred
thousand of the poorest public housing
residents in local elementary schools
here most children receive free meals 30
million US children get free or
reduced-priced meals at school recent
proposed changes by the Trump
administration would strike half a
million from the program nationwide
there are nearly 13 million kids living
in poverty according to the activist
group the Children's Defense Fund
that's nearly one out of every five
children in the United States poverty
affects kids ability to learn the number
one indicator that actually affects
student's education level and achieve
level is poverty raising a family in
poverty is an emotional burden for
caregivers like Michelle Becerra I feel
I was already a pretty humble person but
now I just felt degraded you know and
just look down on humiliation hunger and
homelessness in the wealthiest state in
the wealthiest country on earth rob
reynolds al jazeera Watsonville
California